I'm a deputy assistant to the president
Pop's news contributor Sebastian Gorka
Fox News legal analyst Barry Jarrett
let's go to Weissman let's go we
reported last week the Justice
Department had opened up it's now been
going on for months an investigation
into uranium one is this the first of
many cards to fall yeah it probably is
and you know your opening monologue
about Wiseman is right on point if this
guy actually exchanged information about
mana Ford and then join the
investigation in a manta Ford he's
violating DOJ rule what would you do if
your man affords attorneys tonight I
would do want to think two things I
would file a motion to dismiss which
would trigger the judge to order
Weitzman to show up in court and explain
immediately immediately the judge except
this conflict and his track record any
good judge would not which is why the
second thing I would do is make a motion
for order of inquiry into the conflict
of interests and list mana Ford and
others like rod Rosenstein as witnesses
in the case because they osoon can you
expedite that you could do it within 30
to 60 days Wow and if they are
designated to be defense witnesses they
have to be removed from the case because
there have to be yet they would
absolutely my over the target is this
all as corrupt as I think it is as
corrupt it's probably more corrupt than
we know sebastian Gorka your take on all
this a lot of moving parts here tonight
look Greg outlined exactly the conflict
of interest issue but I'd like to just
pull it up a bit to the strategic level
and I know you've got mark coming on
Mark Levin the great one I don't I don't
want to steal his thunder but mark levin
is nailed it on his show today on radio
he's talking about this as a domestic
surveillance scandal and that's what it
is America doesn't have a secret police
it doesn't have an internal police force
that spies on its own citizens for
political reasons at least it didn't
until President Obama became the
president we now have a story that you
can read in the unclassified press about
Russian disinformation material being
paid for by the FBI and being used to
get fire
so warrants to spy on US Nationals who
are part of a political campaign and
opposition party Kansas so election year
and spy on the president like alright I
want to ask you an offbeat question sure
if we know WikiLeaks and Julian Assange
and I've interviewed him five times if
we know he's the one guy that knows
where he got the information from the
DNC the emails a sir right why is it
Muller contacted him wouldn't he be the
one guy that you'd want to talk to to
find out if Russia gave it to him yes
but that might actually help Donald
Trump and it's pretty clear that that's
what Muller and his team of partisans
don't want to do they want to hurt Trump
not help Trump they're not searching for
evidence they don't want truth because
you say no they don't want the truth
no they would prefer to subvert the
tree-like I'm Jack Nicholson you can
handle it yes you're right
Sebastian last word there are some a
handful of large political scandals in
American history JFK's assassination
then we have Watergate and then we have
the Pentagon Papers
I think this scandal will turn out to be
one of the biggest political scandals in
the history of the United States I
talked to a high high ranking individual
today won't tell you who said this makes
Watergate in terms of Pfizer
surveillance abuses alone one look like
kindergarten I agree this will be up
there with the assassination of JFK this
is how big this is the political
targeting of your enemies using the
intelligence is the key they did it to
over to win an election and an overturn
a newly elected president good to see
you but you agree with that I agree it's
undermining electoral democracy and
blatantly subverting jump there's the
media of Greg I'm not the only it
doesn't fit with their narrative good
point
all right thank you both